um okay so
first before i get started on talking
about macaulay too i want to get a feel
for the audience and uh how much people
know how many people
have uh
have actually started up macaulay 2 at
some point not actually
and how many people have actually used
it for a computation
but how many people have actually saved
code
that they've written
quite a few but there's a lot of people
who here who aren't raising their hands
either so i'm going to try to do a
little bit of each thing here so
so there are a couple purposes of this
talk
uh the first is first of all can you see
this screen or one of the side ones i
can make it larger if you need
so i want to give you an idea of what
macaulay can two can do in this kind of
area with tensors and
maybe
and seeking varieties and things like
this
just a little idea and also oh and just
every now and then i'll say a couple
things about some of the new features of
the just most recently released version
1.7 which has just been released last
week a couple weeks
and
hopefully this will give you some tools
that you can go and if you aren't
familiar with this you can go and
use it to play around with
on this
okay
so the first one i want to do i have a
whole bunch of little vignette type
examples some of them are are a little
more involved than others but uh we'll
see how how we go the first thing i
wanted to do is is basically deal with
some tensor
spaces
three-way tensors so a b and c here are
going to be vector spaces probably two
or three dimensional for the moment
and i'm just in star star is actually
how you write tensor product in macaulay
ii
and uh we're going to investigate like
the segre and the secant loci to these
things
um so let's do the equations of the
secret embedding so this is sort of like
bread and butter macaulay ii you you
make an ideal you do a few things like
figure out the degree the dimension of
it the free resolution hilbert function
stuff like that so we'll just do that
right now
just to get it going i i'm choosing um a
finite field here z mod 30 2003 that's
my favorite i could do q but in a little
bit i'm going to be doing some random
stuff and then the numbers get really
huge if you do that which we could do
but it's hard to see what's going on
so uh
so there's that
i don't really need these but this is
just uh to put them up i'm gonna
a is gonna be just k
k k is the field and uh this is the free
module of the vector space of of
dimension two b is also going to be of
dimension two
and c is dimension two
and then if i want the tensor product of
these i can do a star star b star star c
okay so this is somehow
if i just want vector spaces now that
said that's not what we're going to do
here
by the way this can be a little bit in
interactive too if you want i can get
off of the my canned uh script so you
can just ask about that what does it
make you say for a basis
at the moment a basis of b will be just
it'll just be zero one zero and zero one
yeah so this k8 at the moment does not
remember where it came from
it's it's just
all of the um or all the it takes the
bases of a b and c and then writes them
out in the standard order we'll see what
order in in a bit but uh
so in fact we're not going to use that
that part at the moment that's just to
set this set the scene so for the moment
we're going to look at p1 cross p1 cross
p1
and we're going to embed it into what
projective 7 space right it's um
is there um that's an eight dimensional
thing so i'm going to make a ring
here
uh if you can see it i hope you can at
the bottom it has variables a1 a2 b1 b2
and c1 c2 are those are going to they're
just variables but they're sort of
thinking you think of them as the basis
elements or the coordinate functions on
each of those
and then s is going to be the polynomial
ring in eight variables which i write in
just x underscore 1 1 1. if you haven't
seen macaulay 2
underscore is underscoring brackets are
different from other programming
languages
underscore is like tech it's
it's subscripts
brackets we didn't use for subscripts
because we really wanted math to work so
we wanted to be able to use polynomial
rings and so we were had various things
we had to do
to get around that so one of them was to
change what the subscript was so this is
giving us the dot dot gives us all eight
of the variables in some order which
we'll see what it is in a bit
um oops so i guess we won't see right
away so um now i'm going to make some
matrices in this ring
i'm going to make three matrices uh one
for the a's the b's and c's just uh
so there's a matrix there's the b matrix
there's the c matrix
and now i'm going to make a ring map
from the ring s which is all eight
variables to the uh one with the
variables uh
uh the a's the b's and the c's
okay and here you can see what order it
chose to do this tensor product in so
it's a one b one b1 c1 and so on so it's
all these monomials
okay can you all
i don't know where to stand here so okay
well with the order dot dot put the
eight variables in
um
yes by hopefully by design
i'm pretty sure we did that by design
okay so anyway this is the this is the
the map that goes from the one the p1
cross p1 cross p1 into p7 or given by
these monomials in those things if you
need it there's also markers under there
right okay
yeah i'm going to use that in a bit but
for the moment and if you need me to
write more detail please tell me and
i'll just i'll write things up on here
so if it's going
uh if i know that sometimes seeing just
seeing stuff like this can uh not work
out
double star on this little a little b
little c second the chronicle product of
matrices so what is it doing yeah so a
star star is taking a tensor product of
matrices which is identical to the
chronicle product of the matrices it but
it orders them in a
where well you can sort of see this is
the kind of order it it uses
so um the the first one is done is the
outward um uh one the second the b's are
the middle one and then c's are the one
that move the fastest
can we see just a a star star b
c so if i do a star star b oops a a star
star bb
i get this now it's written in a
here let me just do ideal of that
oh by the way is the last thing that you
did and ooo is the previous thing it
doesn't you get don't get to go back
thousands of times but you get a few
like that
so anyway here's the order so a1 b1 then
a1 b2 a2 b1
a2 b2 can we see the variable for this
yes
so that let's do gens of what was it s
so here are the variables so hopefully
it's the same order
it is good that would have been um
annoying if that had not been okay so
anyway that uh so that's uh that
okay and now let's see we can take the
kernel of this ring map
sometimes kernels of ring maps don't
work so well because it's a a very uh
compute intensive thing but on this sort
of small thing it works fine
and
let's see you can hardly see what that
is so let me um do i have anything in
here
not yet
so let's
let me do a here's the way i like to do
this although i have a
way of so these are the the generators
of this ideal in the variable so it's
the image of the secret embedding of p1
cross p1 plus p1 is given by nine
quadratic polynomials
okay we can count and then now now's the
bread and butter sort of thing you have
an ideal you want to find out something
about it so you have various commands
there's the dimension of it
which is four
now is that right um p1 cross p1 cross
p1 maps into p7
actually let me use some stuff here
so i have p1
cross p1
cross p1
mapping into say x which is contained in
p7
so the x has dimension three but of
course this is the dimension of the
ideal which is it doesn't think of it in
projective things so it's it's doing it
in side of eight variables so it's of
dimension four the cone over it
um or the co dimension in this case is
four also
so it's a it's degree it's dimension
three inside of here which is co
dimension four
let's see what other things did i say oh
yeah what's the degree of this thing
and hilbert series so the hilbert series
is just of of the image
is just a generating function for the
degrees in each degree and this is of
this form
1 minus 9t squared and so on
over 1 minus t to the number of
variables
sometimes you want to get rid of the you
want to divide this is actually
something that's held in a non-evaluated
form inside of macaulay 2.
so you could evaluate it but
but instead you want to reduce it
there's a reduce hilbert function it's
kind of it seems a little bit of a hack
to do that but
um
but
that's the way it is here and o is the
previous thing so this just
wipes out as many 1 minus ts as possible
so you get 1 plus 4t plus t squared
you can
the degree is actually the sum of those
guys which is six you can see lots of
information from it it looks like it's
probably colin mccauley which actually
we know is true as well but any case
whatever
then the other thing that you oftentimes
want is the free resolution of the ideal
in eight variables
and that's it
all
maps in macaulay 2 are written
from the right to the left
that was done also on purpose um for
better or worse
the reason it's done is to keep the
number of rows and number of columns
sort of to match up with the the way
that you write it things in general
and the betty diagram is is actually
instead of looking at all the maps this
gives you information on the degrees let
me just sort of say what this means
uh the one is because it's an ideal the
nine is actually the nine quadratic
generators
and it's quadratic because it goes um
you it goes one and then two then there
are 16 uh linear syzygies on this now is
are people comfortable with syzygies and
things like this here
how about like this
so let's see that's o25 is the is the
resolution
if i want a map i can do dd that gives
me the whole chain complex map so like
for instance if i look at the
zero if i look at the second one this
will be the first syzygy map
okay well it looks like a bit of a mess
but it's not too bad
you find that on the first and second or
the zeroth and first second third and
fourth you're on those four generators
if i multiply the first generator by
that second by that
and then the corresponding ones by those
i get zero
and then if i get each column here is
one of these syzygies
and uh all possible systems any
polynomial that dots to zero with the
first nine is uh is a polynomial
combination of all of these um
guys here
so this is the and these are minimal
sets and it's homogeneous
um let's look at the next one
okay these are the syzygies on those
guys
so
it's hard to tell what what's going on
you'd have to get into it and take a
look at it but actually uh it's the
structure of these things is not trivial
at all in fact there's a whole ton of
interesting open questions
about these
which
anyway
how about the next one
and then there's one last one actually
in this case uh this this thing was
gornstein so the resolution is self-dual
so this is actually the first these are
the nine generators again and actually
in the correct basis that nine that 16
by nine matrix there is the same as the
previous one that we saw transposed
um if you do it in the right order
okay so anyway so this is sort of
playing around with this you could also
calculate the secant locus
to this variety
one way to do that
i'm going to give you a naive way just
to sort of see how it works let's
calculate the second secant locus
of this thing or of x inside of here
what's the expected dimension by the way
of that
so this has dimension uh this has
dimension three in here
whoops the the uh the secant locus you
expect to how do you give a element of
the second locus you give two points on
the uh on the variety and then some
point on the line connecting these
things
so two points is dimension six three and
three and then one for the line so it's
dimension seven so in case there's some
issue maybe it's less than that but
otherwise it's at most dimension seven
so if the ideal of the secant locus is
zero then it's dimension seven otherwise
it sits on something smaller
so
oh yeah but i i didn't do that one
because that one's too boring because it
so i switched it to now p1 cross p1
cross p2
okay
and the way i did this is perhaps a
little bit of just a straightforward
hack but what i do is i use i have
variables a1 a2 b1 b2 and now i have c1
c2 c3 because i'm going to use p1 cross
p1 cross p2
okay just to get something a little more
interesting
and now i have those variables those are
the ones for the first copy of x and
then i have d's e's and f's for the
second copy of x
and then i'm doing secant lines so i
have s and t
does that make sense
so i have all these variables
and now i have the um the final ring
which is going to be um k of x um 1 1 1
2 2 3 this time so we're going to be in
12 variables
and now i'm doing the same thing as we
just did above i'm making the a the b
the c matrix but now it's c1 c2 c3
i do the a2 and b2 and c2 for the second
copy
of uh
of the variables
and now here's the map
can you see this so basically oops i
should have i could have written s times
this here i i did star star for s is a
polynomial when you write star star it's
the same as star essentially
so this is the map a tensor b tensor c
that we had before this is a2 tensor b2
tensor c2
that's so this is the image of the of
one of the points and that's the image
of the other and then i'm just taking
the linear combination of these s times
one plus t times the other
and then the map is this is uh
the corresponding now i have x cross x
uh it's now but x is isomorphic to um p1
cross p1 cross p2
and cross p one
and this is mapping into p
uh now what size am i in i'm in um two
two and three so i'm mapping to p12 well
p11 i mean one less than um 12. is this
okay with everyone am i are people
actually able to follow what i'm doing
here um if not please uh slow me down so
anyway so i actually i'm actually taking
two copies of this thing and so i have
huge numbers of copy of things here and
i'm looking at the map in
so that's the map and it's given by a
fairly complicated thing if you do this
on a large case you're going to be out
of luck it's going to i mean we if
you're familiar with secant loci at all
the equations are extremely interesting
lots of people here have done some
really interesting work on them but the
equations are really nasty well actually
they're beautiful but they're big okay
so um so they don't necessarily come out
good but in this case
the kernel comes out fairly easily
um so i don't want to do the resolution
yet let's just do
let's see that's my own routine so let's
do netlist
that list is a way of displaying it with
these boxes
and if i take the idea of the secant two
underscore star is underscore one zero
one two or all the generators of it this
is a list of all the generators dan will
explain more about the language and
stuff as we go um next uh next talk so
here are the here are the uh
generators there are four generators
actually it turns out that they're
they're all determinants of three by
three determinants
um oops
what's this
what happened here i think you had meant
i hadn't done the
resolution okay and now um
okay oo dot dd underscore two so the
free resolution of these four generators
only has three linear scissors um for
three first synthesis
and if i look at those i get the three
by four
four by three matrix
uh whose determinants actually are the
things
okay
okay so that's all are there any
questions on that so this is just sort
of um you can at least get some basic
sequential if you want to do larger ones
you we have to be trickier about it um
to what we do
however um what i wanted to now is show
one use of uh i wanted to talk about
deficient triple segways yep
how many variables can you actually do
this for that's a good question
um
can you go quite a ways at a certain
point what you want to do is not use the
kernel command for a ring map you have
to drop it down into actual grubbner
basis computation because you need finer
control over the um only doing part of
the computation
uh it would be nice if the ring map if
this kernel command handled that it
would be nice but we haven't done that
so in other words you want it up through
a specific degree if you know that
you're going to have a certain number of
degree generators this goes through
until it's done
it doesn't at the moment it should it
would be nice if someone wrote that
i used to be i would say oh i'll write
that but now i just say be nice if
someone else wrote that
so anyway what i want to talk about
though is i want to now consider
i'm going to get rid of this here
i want to now consider
uh
all various
things of the following form i want to
consider pa
let's write this better
i have my vector space is a
and b
and c
and i want to go into p of a tensor b
tensor c
just like we've been doing for these
special cases but now i want to consider
uh the dimension of the secant loci of
this and we have a good technique for
doing that
um
yeah so
if let's call the dimension of a
of the vector space a n a the one here n
b and the this one n c just as a sort of
general consistency thing
uh then we certainly know the expected
dimension and sort of what i was saying
before
uh
this n a minus 1 plus n b minus 1 plus
nc minus 1 is actually the dimension of
that that image of that thing and then
we have that um if we're taking the seek
r that's our points that we're taking on
it so we're gonna have r times that
plus we're gonna have r minus one uh
for the projective r minus one space
that where that when we fill up the so
we're taking r points on it and then
we're taking the linear space of that
and then we're taking the union of all
these planes is this okay so this is the
expected dimension of the secant locus
it's probably something
how many of you are familiar with the
the uh
how many of you are not familiar with
seek and loci
okay
does this make sense that i'm talking so
you have secant lines through it but you
also have secant planes where you take
three points and for every three points
on it you take the plane
through that and then you take the union
of all these planes and then or r equals
four r equals five at some point you're
going to fill up some it's going to get
as large as possible maybe worth writing
it down yep
okay
so uh
so seek r
of x
x this is going to map into x here
is equal
to the um
let's write this down this is the union
all over all points p1 to pr in x
distinct points
and we take the
the linear span of these points which is
an r minus one dimensional um
uh linear space
these are all distinct though so this is
sort of an open thing this is all
sitting inside of uh this space here
so we have to actually take the closure
of this this space and that's the secant
locus and then the expected dimension
is equal to
well it could be the whole space here
which is um
which is n a times n b
times nc minus one
uh
if if the other number is much larger
than that then this will this will mean
that the secant locus fills up the whole
space
or it could mean uh it could be that
it has the dimension of this x which is
n a
minus 1 plus n b minus 1 plus nc minus
1.
so that's this minus 3
and then we have r times this
plus r minus one
okay which is the same thing i wrote
here if you do the earth
okay so that's the expected dimension of
the secant locus
i did three terms because two terms is
actually you can write down completely
what's going on three terms has got a
lot of interesting things going on uh
with it
okay now a variety is called deficient
or r deficient i don't know exactly what
the term is if this secant locus has
does not have this expected dimension
has lower dimension than this there's a
bunch of cases and i just wanted to sort
of use mcaulitude to sort of analyze
what that is
you can't have higher than this this is
the maximum dimension that the second
locus can have um if you think about it
so our goal is going to be to find all
of the deficient
triples in other words the dimensions of
a b and c and r
so that these are deficient
um up through
some size of dimensions i mean we this
isn't a theoretical result this is just
playing around a little bit with the
system okay we can't we're not going to
compute the these ideals and then figure
out the dimension that's not going to
work um we can do it for those simple
cases but very very soon is these are
going to get to be very large
and um part of what this whole workshop
is to to consider these these ideals
but we're going to use terracini's lemma
are you familiar with taratini's lemma
um
so suppose we have x
is contained inside of some projective
space
and we have i'm going to think of let's
actually think of this as p on some
vector space
so okay so v is actually n plus one
dimensional here and then we look at the
cone x hat
this is equal to the cone on x can you
is my handwriting large enough
um for you way over there baron can you
see that um so this is uh
what i can see very well oh it's
actually being projected sometimes okay
cool
so uh so x hat is actually the affine
space uh this is the affine cone over
this
and if if we take if we let p
be a point in x well
in our cases i want it to be a smooth
point
on x
then i have the tangent space of x hat
maybe x hat smooth
on p so this is a this is some tangent
space
and this sits inside of the tangent
space on uh of this which is just v
so this is actually a vector subspace of
v okay so i'm going to write this uh
this thing and now terracini
i hope i'm ready for to write this down
uh so we're going to um
so what i want to
say is suppose let's let
p1
to pr
inside of x
the pretty much general points is the
way i'm going to be doing it but be
smooth points
okay so if x is um
and distinct
okay
and now i want to let p
uh be inside the linear span
of these p1 to pr
so this is going to be a point in the
secant variety of this thing
okay
and i want to say let this be a general
point um of this
basically i just wanted it to be a
smooth point of the secant locus okay
then what we
know is that the tangent
space of the secant locus
seek r
of x
at the point p
maybe i need to put a little hat in here
so because i want it to be a subspace of
this vector space okay
that this is actually equal
to the sum
of
the tangent space at exit p1
that's vector space inside of v and we
add that up but
all the way up to all um
p sub r of these guys
okay so it's a really cool thing it's
actually very pretty straightforward to
prove but it's a it's a nice thing so
why is it nice because if we could
sample points of x
uh and
we're going this is all heuristic we're
not proving anything here okay we're
sampling them we're hoping them that
they're in the smooth
locus which actually in this case they
will be since
uh there it's x's itself smooth
but then we're going to uh take a
general point and this guy here will be
just the sum of these vector spaces so
we'll know that we can know the
dimension of this
space um because this will be the
dimension of the secant locus for a
general point okay so we're going to use
this to sort of uh figure out uh
dimensions of these things
so does this make sense so our goal is
pretty simple we have to uh we're going
to
uh for given this um this a cross p a b
cross p c we're going to actually um
sample from it and find our points on it
okay and then we're going to uh
we're not even going to bother taking a
point in here we're just going to take
the sum of those tangent spaces so we
have to figure out what the tangent
space is as well and then we have to sum
them and then once we've got that
we can just take the dimension of it and
get it okay
now if this is um
yep might be worth pointing out that the
naive bound on the dimension of secant
variety is exactly like thinking that
all of these tangent spaces are oh yeah
that's right all right so if the all
these tangent spaces
um
are
if this is a
direct sum uh in other words they don't
have any pairwise intersection then that
will exactly give this bound that we
have here
um
well except for the unless it's this
value here
um so
so i think this is just telling me so
this is
the uh terracini lemma so our plan is to
choose random points
and then to compute this embedded
tangent space that i was talking about
of the cone
and then take the sum and then we'll
just take the dimension of that
okay
uh it is possible that the dimension is
higher than we compute
it's actually lower than we compute
um
but it's very rare that that will happen
okay
unless we chose a very small finite
field
or something
so okay so let's okay i have a bunch of
writing here by the way we'll put these
notes on on on the the web so that you
can just sort of go through them in more
leisure later on
i'm using working over this finite field
uh in part because i'm going to do
random points that was what i actually
actually i didn't realize i redid it i
could have done q before
so now we're going to take a b and c to
be our two our vector spaces we're going
to start with a b and c being dimension
two and just do it by hand then we'll
make a function that does it all for us
and then we'll rip through all of these
examples
okay so here is v uh this is the same
one we did before a tensor b tensor c
now i'm going to write a function i
guess i am writing a function that is
going to sample a point on the sig gray
how do i do that
well
in this case what i want to do is i want
to choose a random point here
a random point here and a random point
here
and then all i have to do if i think of
them as matrices
um i will just tensor product all those
matrices together and i'll get my random
point in the image which is where i want
it
so let's see if i get it this is how we
do functions in macaulay too you sample
say gray is the name of it and a
function is just arguments arrow and
then some expression
so i'm letting k be the ring of a
that's going to be just this z mod 30
2003
and then i'm going to take a random map
from k1 into the vector space a okay
and then i'm going to take random map
from k1 into b
and then a random one k one into c
why is the column equals now and how do
you get to the next row and stuff like
that yes
okay
so first of all what i'm doing here um i
should tell you i'm using
emacs and macaulay 2 inside of emacs and
i have this key where i hit f11 and it
just brings up the next line for me
f12 starts at it's a maybe dan will say
a couple words about this also
equals is uh assignment
uh inside of a function where's this
parenthesis uh colon equals is defining
a local variable
um
so so k is now a local variable if you
have it's not overriding the the global
one that we've got
um a b and c are now these random things
and now i'm going to return a list of
four things right actually it's called
the sequence in macaulay ii of of a b
and c we're actually going to need that
to compute the tangent space
but the actual point is the is the last
one this a star star b star star c
so this doesn't make sense i just want
to make sure i'm not losing anyone with
this because i know that so basically
what we want to do is we want to just
sample from this element we want to find
a point on the image here
and uh that's a function
of vector spaces
yeah so the the the function takes three
vector spaces a b and c
um that we've
any of them but like the ones we've
defined
and then it will return actually more
than just the point it returns the three
points in a b and c plus the actual
point in the segreg
okay
i mean in the image
so let me let's see here here's a point
one sample segregated from hey remember
a b and c at the moment are just k twos
okay so two dimensional vector spaces so
what does it return
it's just returning and this is why you
didn't use q because otherwise these
would get to be nasty well maybe this is
you consider nasty i don't know
but in any case uh so this is the point
in a point in b point and c and then
that's just the tensor product of all
those things in the correct order that
we've been doing in the past same order
okay
now
what if you need to sample from a
variety that you don't have here we have
a map into it it's a nice rational
variety
so
it's really easy to sample we choose
random things and we do it what if it's
just a variety given by equations how do
we sample that
that actually can be very very difficult
thing to do that's where numerical
algebraic geometry comes in and uh at
some point i don't know if anton will do
it but maybe i'll say something uh where
is anton and uh
and uh
you can use uh
the stuff that anton and some others
have written and you can use either the
stuff uh well i'll talk more about this
uh later i hope
but right now we can just do it by
because we have it embedded we can just
do it this way
um okay so now how do we get the
embedded tangent space
so here is a function i'm going to just
so
jacobian map is actually going to be the
map
given the point in abc it's going to
give me a map whose columns span the
tangent space
uh this embedded tangent space
and it's actually pretty easy if you
think about it this is actually
taken essentially out of luke odin's
notes which i believe are on the
web page for um this um
i'm not actually sure where they're on
website bootcamp okay so basically uh
what you the way you get it is you take
so
all indexing is done from zero in
macaulay too i did it
it's a little tricky because i did x
underscore one one one two two two two
but i chose it
not to be from zero but here it point
uh there are four things that's zero the
first the second and the fourth
component so point zero i tensor with
point one when i tensor with a vector
space that's really tension with the
identity map so it's it's allowing that
one to be completely variable
and then i have to do the same thing for
the second so um i have i i fixed the
the first and the third and then i let b
the middle one be arbitrary and
similarly i let the i fix the first the
second and third and i let the first one
be arbitrary those give me a bunch of
maps and uh and then i concatenate them
all together so you'll see in a second
i hope okay so here's what it gives you
the jacobian map of 0.1 and abc
so what's really going on is these first
two are this map here it takes just
these part here and then tensor with the
identity and you can sort of see
identity i you know there's a these are
the same same same and same okay
and now these are tensor with the
identity but it's a little harder to see
because it's in different places
and similarly so this is these are the
three parts
so there's um
so the the tangent space is actually
generated by the columns of these
matrices so there's six of them so if
they're independent then this thing has
dimension six
however it isn't independent it has rank
four
and that's actually always going to be
the case because uh these vector these
tangent spaces always have the point
that you start at in common
and so in fact you're going to get a
couple um uh combinations that are the
same so anyway this has rank four which
means that the image of this um
of this uh this tan this tangent space
in the image has
uh dimension four
well wait a second so remember this is
um this was p1 cross p1
cross p1
mapping into p7
and i just sampled a single point in
here
and i uh
and i took its tangent space
but this is dimension three but i'm
getting four so what do i what have i
done wrong
i haven't done anything wrong
um but but you what we have is that the
tangent space here is of the cone so
instead of dimension three it's the
tangent space of a four-dimensional
thing so it's one higher than the
tangent space
uh that you would expect in projective
space
okay so the rank is four
so the the actual tangent space in
projector space would be one less
dimension which is three-dimensional
which is actually what you would expect
for a three-dimensional point on a
three-dimensional variety that's smooth
could we have also used macaulay ii to
just compute the jacobian of the
parametrization map instead of writing
it out we certainly could do that
except it's a little tricky because it's
um we have to make sure we have it right
because it's it's a um
i guess we could because it's um
we would just we could just take the the
map and then just differentiate with all
of those should we do that
um let's do that in a little a little
later
but yeah so we could just do that and
then and then just randomly choose
points inside of that also um maybe that
would have been a little better
a little easier
however now what we want to do
is we're going to now take we're going
to consider for this one we're going to
consider the secant locus of two points
and so i'm going to take another point i
have point one already now i take point
two as a sampling on the same thing it's
just some other point
and now how do i get uh
the the sum of the two vector spaces
here i just concatenate the two matrices
the jacobian map because it's the it's
the span of the columns so i just put
them and then in macaulay ii a vertical
bar like this is just putting two
matrices um slamming them all all the
columns together
so when i do that what do i get
i get
this is the first one two three four
five six this is what we had before at
least i hope it is and now this is the
same thing but with the new random point
okay
so we have 12
uh
things
and now the rank of that
is in fact eight which is the whole
space so in this case that uh
so the the when i take two points and i
have a
tangent space i'm getting the entire
space so that tells us
that uh
that that secant locus uh
is eight dimensional which is the uh
well is eight affine dimensional so it's
uh the image of the secant locus is
everything
does that make sense
yes
and that's exactly what we expected um
these ends are two each
two plus two plus two
minus three is what that six minus three
is three
what
maybe there is a minus two
otherwise it does not match yeah no no i
think i have a plus or minus one over
here though
i did it a little is it did i screw up
okay i put r later just because i was
the way i had done it so here this is um
two plus two plus two minus three is
three that's the dimension of the space
times 2 is 6
plus 1 is
7. that's projective dimension that we
expect so we expect for dim and that's
the same as this also so
both of them are 7 dimensional and since
we're getting rank eight for the affine
tangent space
that's exactly what we expected
so it's
it's um it's got to be the whole space
well the closure of it is
okay any questions about that
so basically we sampled we calculated
these tangent things by using this
jacobian map and then we took uh we just
took the rank of that um the
concatenation of these guys and we got
uh the dimension that we expect so now
what i want to do is actually use
macaulay 2 to sort of combine these into
a function so that we can actually rip
through
all of the ones that we want so we can
actually keep track of which ones are
deficient deficient meaning it doesn't
match this dimension of course it might
be that it's not it's it's really not
just efficient it might just be that
we've computed it poorly we just happen
to choose bad values for our random
values but i've never seen that happen
in this example in the several
thousand times
done this kind of thing so
um here's another way of getting it by
the way in macaulay too when you the
matrix you can you give it so curly
braces are a list
in macaulay 2. so you give it a list of
lists of things usually it's a list of
list of of elements in the ring and then
it makes a matrix but you can also give
a list of list of
of
matrices and it will do block matrix
form so in this way uh this here is one
matrix which is this and that's another
one and it's only one row of block form
so
that's what you get and the reason i
mentioned that is we're going to use
that in the in the code because it's a
little easier
okay so let's make a so we're going to
have a couple functions
so
the first one is oh yeah so this is
going to give us the expected not
expected dimension the actual one that
we compute using this lemma
okay so
uh so this is going to be a function
that takes a whole ton of stuff it takes
r which is what secant locus we're
looking at
and then it takes the three dimensions n
a and b and nc
and it takes a field where we're going
to do the computations in this case
it'll be z mod 32 0003 we could do it
over a q or whatever it doesn't really
matter doing it over z mod 2 would
probably be bad
okay
and now what we do is we actually make
the three vector spaces
k to raise to the n a and b and then c
here because we have to have those
floating around somewhere
what else do we need to do
we need to sample that's the next thing
that we did after creating these things
we have to find our points here's one
way to do it in macaulay 2
you do with a for loop 4i from 1 to r
you do list and then you call your
function in this case it's the one we
had before which samples from then
that's why we wrote it to have it here
actually
so this is going to return a list of our
things which will be our sample points
what do we need after that
um after we sampled it we need all the
tangent spaces so uh again now for each
point in this is points as a list for
point endpoints that does it for every
element of the list
uh it lists the jacobian map um so it's
going to be the result of that is going
to be a whole bunch of matrices
okay just like we did before
i hope that um
if this is being too much at one time
you got to tell me and then this thing
here is taking the sum of all those so
we have r
tangent um matrices uh r matrices for
tangent vectors like that and this one
is putting them all together in a row
and finally what do we do we take the
rank of it but that was one off from the
dimension we want so we subtract one
from it
and that is our function okay so does
that make sense it's doing exactly what
we did before but canning it all at one
shot
is the fourth two list is that a
syntactic construct on its own yes
it clips together right yeah so there's
several ways of doing
control structures in macaulay 2 and
this is just one of them
okay so here's one for instance if we
take um three three three so that's p2
across p2 across p2
and we look at we're interested in the
dimensions secant to segreg well over
the field but um and then ours
is going to now range from one to ten
one will be the segre itself that's
certainly a possibility and then it'll
go on up and let's see what we get
okay so it comes out pretty quick
and uh
so it has um
so the segre has dimension six as
expected it's p2 cross p2 cross p2 which
is six dimensional
the next one should have two times that
plus one
which it does the next one should have
three
it's three secants so three times that
plus it's a plane so that's two more
dimensions which it does how about the
next one 25 is that right
if i take four times this that's the
secant four i get 24 plus it's not right
okay so this is actually a really
interesting one um so i don't we have to
one can write down the equation to this
it's a really interesting equation
but i don't have it canned up here and
so but it would be interesting to have a
code that would take use the
representation theory especially
behind these things to actually write
down these equations maybe someone
already has that
variety of is a hypersurface yeah so
this is in a 26 dimensional space and so
this is
what is the domain is that a dimension
um is that a degree 15
that one's degree 9. okay that's the um
strassen commutation
relation right so um
so this is an interesting degree 9
hypersurface
can that be written by the way as a
determinant of a nine by nine
matrix
nine by nine linear matrix not like okay
can it be done using mccauley two code i
can probably show you how to do it in a
couple of lines but not during your
lecture yeah
yeah actually i would like to um
you know get all of those sorts of
things and and also the way of getting
it from the the the young straightening
things or something like that so
um now
we're going to what i want to do is rip
through all of these so i want to have
another function that just computes this
thing here
just so that we can actually test the
actual dimension against the expected
dimension throw those out because
there's going to be a huge number of
those and just keep the ones that are
not
okay so here it is a dimension of x is
uh
is the sum of the n a minus one and b
minus one and then c minus one this is
just to make it a little easier and then
i take the minimum
of uh of these two numbers i have it um
displayed out slightly differently but
that's it
and that's it
okay now deficient what is this gonna do
i forget
let's write it down and see okay
um i didn't write down a comment for
myself which is really stupid um you
should never do that but anyway uh so
to return anything
what is this
it's a deficient function
right
um and also r is set to be two here so
it's not particularly useful i hope i'm
not using this elsewhere
um
yeah
sure i hope i didn't actually
okay um let me tell you what i'm doing
now i want to consider a whole bunch of
triples now of of dimensions of a b and
c but i don't want to overdo it so i
just want to make sure the dimension of
a is less than or equal to dimension of
b less than or equal to the dimension c
between two and n okay so if i give it a
number n it's going to take all the
all the um triples of numbers from
that satisfy this thing so i'm going i
from 2 to n
from j from i
starting at that point all the way up to
n for k starting at that one up to n
these flattens are because otherwise
i'll get lots of um middle lists so if
you play around with this you'll see
that right away
but let's just check this out i'm a
little worried about that deficient
function
well but your expected dimension does
what you want right it computed yeah
yeah no that one is correct it's just
that we got to make sure we don't use
deficient
let me just check one thing
okay good i didn't use it um
okay so um n equals five let's do all
the ones for dimension up to five so all
the ones that have up to projective four
space
okay green is divided now
sorry
how's that
um okay so i'm gonna uh now what i'm
gonna do
is i'm going to just rip through all of
these triples
and calculate
um so what i'm going to do is i'm going
to calculate the expected dimension and
the actual the dimension from this this
count here
and then
basically if they're the same i'm going
to just throw i'm not going to i'm going
to ignore it otherwise i'm going to put
down something so i can see which ones
are deficient
and the first one we should get what we
just got the first one is p2 across p2
right so p2 oh no this is actually p1
cross p1 cross p1 this one here is p2
cross p2 cross p2 and we should get that
um which secant is it four
um is um so we should get three this one
com and r equals four is deficient but
there's others as well
so uh let me um
let me just write this down and i will
go through it
i think that's it okay
so this is not i didn't write it as a
function i could have but basically the
flatten is because i'm going to get a
list of lists so this flattens it into
one long list
ijk and triples of n this is triples of
n or triples of five
and n is five
here's this is called a sort of a
uh uh parallel assignment ijk is a as a
sequence of three things so i'm just
sending them to i j and k okay i should
have sent them to n a n b and n c
um i don't know why i didn't do that
i didn't
i don't know why okay now the top r it
here is the top r
after which um if i didn't make a
mistake it will be the whole space
okay so it's it's the i j k minus one
divided by essentially uh
almost the dimension um
and now for each r in that range
starting at two because i don't i'm not
going to do the sig gray
up to this actually i don't even need to
do two for the most part because there
are theorems that tell me that those are
going to be okay but um
i think that anyway we'll check it
anyway make sure that everyone
everyone get got it right okay so um
and we compute the expected dimension
here and call it expected we calculate
the dimension secant to segway that's
the one that we did all of the stuff for
here
to get it and that gives us a
dimension here which i call d
if d is expected
then what i do
so here's what's going on see this for
something or other to something or other
list what that's doing is it's
collecting the results inside there and
making a list out of it however if you
do continue it doesn't add anything new
to the list
so it just so anyway if it's expected we
just ignore it otherwise we need to mark
down somehow what we got so here's and
this may not be the best way but here's
what i did
this is what i'm returning it's
essentially a whole bunch of numbers i j
and k are the three dimensions
r is which um r we found to be deficient
and this is just the thing in macaulay 2
called an option but it doesn't matter
it's just a way of of getting it to
display nicely in this case
and it's going to show it's going to
on the other side of that guy it's going
to return both d and expected so we can
see what dimension it thinks it is
and uh what the expected dimension was
and how much they're off
and then this will give us a list of all
of the things the flattened on the top
gives us everything so if i hit f11 now
it did all of those already here let's
if i do net list of the previous thing
oo it should um
give it so these are the deficient ones
it's amazing how fast that is yeah
um and uh
so
and here's the three three three four
that we saw
and uh
do you know what this equation is
seven it's in uh it's co dimensions it's
dimension 73 instead of the full 74. i
don't know what it is so
um
it's probably a determinant but do you
think that one's a determinant
it would be nice if it were a lot of
those are hyper surfaces
it's the other yeah the top ones they're
not all um so actually the two two five
the third secant variety to this one is
seven is go dimension two
in here
um
actually this one and this one both are
co-dimension two they're probably coming
about from some similar sort of deal and
then these are hypersurfaces
so now let's actually up the game and do
it we can do it through ninety how about
nine or ten which one should we do is
nine okay
does ten work sure but it takes a little
bit longer
it might be the end of my tongue okay so
um
no okay i have to go back because i have
to rerun that same code oops that's not
the right
uh-oh
okay so i'm going to run this code right
here again okay n is 10
and now i'm going to do that same
loop again i just went back i didn't
have it typed in twice so
so i'm doing exactly the same thing but
now n is 10. oh i should have showed how
many there are though
let me just um let me get rid of that
um
and do tuple what did i call it triples
triples of ten
and actually we can do number of that
just instead of printing them all out
there's 165 cases up there up through so
this is going up through p9 cross p9
cross p9
um okay now i have to go back and get
that again
why does it not go back to the same
okay
maybe you buried it i probably did
okay here it is again okay
n is ten
oops is it doing it
yeah
okay hopefully that's it either that or
we're sitting here waiting for for me to
type something else in which is
certainly a possibility i've done that
before um
you're thinking wow this is taking
really a long time okay
this does take a bit
um
so we'll look at that in in a bit um i
have a bunch of other things i might
like to
talk
about five minutes
five minutes
can maybe do that
um we'll see what
people want okay
so um
so other things that
uh i i
will while that's doing that actually
maybe it's done by now
okay there we go
okay it's done
okay so let's see netlist is next
um
okay so these are all the examples
okay so all the first ones are no not so
these are all the deficient ones of size
less than or equal to um
10 10 10.
okay
notice that um because of the way we
ordered them uh anything with four or
greater is not
deficient ever
is that a theorem by the way it's a
conjecture
okay
so um
so and so
and most of these are hypersurfaces this
one's off by eight though for instance
so it's um
it's
be interesting to understand
all of these just to see in the case the
three odd odds well understood three odd
odds okay yes
yeah
i see so these two are okay how about
these kinds of things
this works because the third one is much
bigger than the product of the first one
i see okay
right i see so
in fact that's almost always oh no wait
it's
coming over not meat is efficient
i see
so anyway so but there's this is already
showing quite
quite a bit and it's actually
you know
you could actually go much higher if you
really um wanted to um it and this are
not completely trivial things because
notice we're doing 10 by 10 by 10 so the
tangent spaces are inside of a thousand
dimensional um vector no wait
yeah thousand dimensional vector space
and so it you know so it's doing it a
bunch of work there
okay
um so we have three minutes left
at least by my um showing maybe four
minutes
and um
so i guess
um i might end up oops that's not what i
want it keeps getting better
um i wanted to show a couple uh simple
things
uh let me do this one first
okay let's start over
um i'm going to do a permanently ideal
question
here that maybe some of you know well
so i'm going to do it over q this time
just for fun i'm going to take a three
by four matrix very simple small matrix
and
maybe you guys have already dealt with
this i know permanent uh so suppose i
take the the um
the three by three permanence of this uh
of this matrix you're all familiar with
permanence
permanence are just uh are the really
cool
um
determinant
uh
alternate
um which would be nice to understand
better but so we're going to have four
permanents here and we'd like to do a
primary decomposition so here's the
permanence
if we want to see them
and yes thanks
let's go the other one though
okay
so let's actually do um
okay so those are the four
that's the same as the determinants with
plus signs
seems i always seem slightly innocuous
but of course it's not and um
and now
there if you do
one way to get the minimal primes to
decompose something to macaulay 2
is to use the decomposed command which
is also called minimal primes
the current code will not finish on this
very very fast however the one of the
things that is new is experimental code
written with uh frank moore and
francisca henkelman
and which was started in various
workshops that we've had
uh and uh so it's in this system but
it's experimental you have to load the
package and then it's called min primes
and then when you do it it comes back
very quickly
if you were paying attention
you saw me load it but for instance
here's where i loaded it
needs package minimal primes okay the
very first thing i did okay
um
so the astute uh you know
reader would have noticed that maybe
okay so um so anyway so we have that and
we have all of these components um
oops that one i already did
well we'll do it again
i don't know why um
okay there are eight components to that
um
here's something in macaulay too that i
tend to use all time if i have c is a
list of eight um ideals here
if i have a list and i use slash and
then a function it applies that function
to every one of these things it's just a
shorthand for for something or other in
c
list trim of that thing or something
like this but this is really convenient
this trim will calculate minimal
generators of each of these things since
they're homogeneous
and now i can look at the list of them
because otherwise it turned out not to
be nice
so here are the components except that
it's it scrolls way off the edge the way
it's done i wonder what the right hand
edge of your window looks like
it's not visible in your
desktop
right it's not
is it visible to
me can you see it now
okay so
a bunch of these are completely
understandable these i mean a bunch of
variables here here let me print the
matrix out so you can see
what's going on
okay so uh
so for instance l-i-f-c so yeah if you
if you nail a row then you have a
component
okay however so all of these ones are
fine this one is very interesting though
um
so that's c underscore seven remember
underscore and then it's the eighth one
on the list which is the index seven and
it says big mess
so let's let's look at it nicer
it goes again off the edge
so we have the four impermanence and now
this is a prime ideal and it has all
these generators okay so we have these
guys of degree six
and then these three of degree eight
does anyone actually uh know what these
are
does anyone ever come across this uh
for instance parent of you know
um
because i i was trying to figure out
what i i do not i don't i cannot figure
out where these things are coming from
yeah yeah
well so like for instance i can look at
one of these polynomials
like these last ones are uh are
polynomials in
uh in a three by three sub determinant
and it's a degree eight polynomial so
what
um so for it's got to be something nice
anyway i don't know what it is but we
can calculate the co-dimension of this
ideal is four its degree is 66.
you can even calculate the free
resolution of it there are 11 generators
of it
and here's the free resolution
that i don't know what it means
what
the singular locus of this it's actually
very interesting
so what we could do is we can do a
minors
of four con it's co-dimension four right
so it's minor is a four comma the
jacobian
of j
we'd better add the ideal jn so this is
the singular locus
of j is equal to this i don't want to
print it so i'm going to do that
um
oh
yep so we'll do that later so anyway um
so but the i wanted to end at that one
because uh
this ideal is one i just don't
understand and it appears uh
in all higher when permanent ideals
obviously when you're resolving it and
so on anyway so that's a good place to
stop so thanks
yeah actually i'm surprised it's taking
a long time to compute it i wonder
there are a lot of four by four miners
in this um
so
i i did do it once i thought but i'll
have to um maybe do it offline um by the
way so dan will show but when you're
using macaulay too there's plenty of
ability to get help
and i didn't actually i was going to do
that and i didn't have it on my thing so
i so you're going to have to wait to see
how to do that when
other questions
okay let's thank mike again